help help me there the sea drinks when
it gets foggy like last night
drowned or captured
Wow you aren't at all what I was
expecting
let's do what brings you to them sneak
up on you it's what I do
Oh charming the maidens wrecked on the
sandy shore as for craft we're going to
disguise my crew with sea Drake's look
for hampers with clothes or kill a sea
Drake and take theirs put on their
clothes and you'll look just lovely
remember you can take clothes from
hampers or off Dead Sea Drake's
oh and try not to get killed
ha please thank the 8 stay away from
Helene she's a monster
these seed rates give pirates a bad name
kill every last one of them you see if
you're going to cop word of advice don't
let them capture you if you can't get
away die fighting
you're a welcome sight I've rescued
everyone but almost done then everyone's
out except my first mate Derek or
they've got him in the belly of Helene
ship you'll find a key
captain Larissa never leaves anyone
behind make sure she's safe
what you're not my what have you did you
poison me captain are you feeling okay
Oh got you like a stuck pig cut your
eyes out roast you like you did my crew
no that won't happen again she fell down
not me
did I do that I'll just be going then I
told my crew to gather on the beach
I'm going to make sure they all made it
out meet me there and we'll square up
I'd feel mildly disappointed but I leave
it up to you meet me on the beach one
[Music]
my crews safe and only well your choice
I hope the next crew she shipwreck
Sandra she's a bit too obsessed with
[Music]
shame about captain huh she's a bit too
obsessed with you